Before you see him soar into action, here's
a look back at some of the other works you
may have seen Zachary Levi star in.
If you were wondering, this is why the actor
playing Shazam looks so familiar.
For his first-ever film gig, Levi nabbed a
supporting role in the TV movie Big Shot:
Confessions of a Campus Bookie.
The film aired on FX in March of 2002, and
although the movie was a dud, it was a great
opportunity for Levi to add a film credit
to his acting resume.
Prior to Big Shot, he had only performed in
theater productions.
With Big Shot, Levi was able to get his feet
wet in Hollywood, which potentially acted
as a springboard for his career's next big
achievement.
ABC's Less Than Perfect was a moderately successful
workplace sitcom that debuted in 2002 and
ran through 2006.
The show followed Sara Rue's Claude Casey,
an employee at a television network.
Other big names in the cast included Sherri
Shepherd and Andy Dick, who played Claude's
coworkers.
However, it was Levi who truly made a name
for himself as Kipp Steadman, Claude's elitist
frenemy and primary rival.
He appeared in all 81 episodes of the series.
"We're gonna pretend like you guys didn't
do this on purpose."
"Can we at least give it a shot?"
Playing Kipp, Levi started to see his life
change.
In a 2003 interview with Relevant Magazine,
the then-22-year-old opened up about his newfound
fame:
"It's weird.
To me, it hasn't all completely sunk in yet.
But at the same time, I hope it never does…
I hope there's always at least a small part
of me that's always surprised, always taken
aback, always childlike or innocent in the
whole process."
Considering that in Shazam! he played a 14-year-old
in an adult's body, Levi apparently got his
wish.
2006's Big Momma's House 2 starred Martin
Lawrence reprising his role of FBI agent Malcolm
Turner and his undercover alter ego "Big Momma."
Although its premise is very similar to the
first film, the sequel does inject a few new
faces to its story.
One of those new additions is Zachary Levi,
who plays an FBI agent.
Although Big Momma's House 2 failed to live
up to its predecessor in terms of both revenue
and reviews, it was actually a huge milestone
for Levi's career, marking the first time
his presence would grace the big screen in
theaters.
You can safely assume that being on the set
of a film with a production budget of $40
million was at least slightly different from
Levi's sitcom experience.
In his breakthrough role on NBC's cult favorite
TV series Chuck, Levi played Chuck Bartowski,
computer-geek-turned-secret-agent.
The show perfectly showcased Levi's full arsenal
of acting chops, from humorously innocent
to surprisingly badass.
"C-Casey?"
His chemistry with Yvonne Strahovski, who
portrayed Chuck's CIA handler Sarah Walker,
also proved that he could convincingly maintain
a love interest on-screen.
Chuck was a major part of Levi's life, and
it isn't a role he’ll soon to forget.
Speaking with Entertainment Weekly, Levi didn't
hide his desire to make a Chuck full-length
feature film:
"I'd love to do it.
As far as I know, I'm the only person who's
affiliated with the show that's been trying
to make it happen on some level.
I've had meetings with various people.
There's just so many moving parts."
If Levi's career continues to blossom, don't
be surprised to see Chuck: The Movie eventually
hit theaters.
After the first season of Chuck, Levi starred
in the road trip comedy Wieners.
In the film, Levi, Keenan Thompson, and Fran
Kranz play three friends who embark on a cross-country
mission to hunt down a talk-show host who's
wronged one of them.
Oh, and they drive a hot dog-shaped vehicle
to get there.
Obviously.
Unsurprisingly, Wieners failed to impress
audiences and was possibly a low point for
Levi's budding career.
However, he had to know that the movie wasn't
exactly going to be up for any awards from
the start.
The hot dog car was probably the first of
several clues.
2008's Shades of Ray is difficult to assign
a specific genre.
With layers of comedy, drama and romance,
it's sort of a cinematic hodgepodge.
The indie film tells the story of Ray, whose
parents are of different ethnic backgrounds,
and his quest to find the right woman.
In the movie, Levi starred in the title role
as Ray, marking his first film appearance
as the main protagonist.
Although Shades of Ray wasn't a box office
hit, it did well on the festival circuit,
winning various awards.
Sure, it's cool to be able to say you've starred
in projects alongside Hollywood legends like
Clint Eastwood, Tom Hanks, or Meryl Streep,
but only a very select few have the super-cool
privilege of saying they've starred alongside
Alvin and the Chipmunks.
In 2009's Alvin and the Chipmunks: The Squeakquel,
Levi played Toby, the video game-obsessed
cousin of Jason Lee's Chipmunk-daddy Dave.
The kids movie was a major box office hit,
raking in over $443 million worldwide and
becoming the ninth top-grossing movie of the
year.
Good job, Levi!
"Oh man!
It burns!"
In RocketJump Studios' web series Video Game
High School, video gaming has become the most
popular sport in the future, and VGH is an
organization that teaches a wide curriculum
of various gaming genres.
The series has built up a cult following since
it kicked off in 2012.
Although he only appeared in three episodes,
Levi's time on VGHS left a lasting impression.
His Texas drawl and deadpan attitude makes
the introduction to his first-person shooter
course arguably one of the best scenes in
the show's first season.
"Hello students, and welcome to FPS 101.
My name is Ace, you can call me Ace.
Sound good?
Fantastic."
Zachary Levi made comic book movie headlines
in 2012 when it was announced that he would
replace Josh Dallas as Fandral in Thor: The
Dark World.
Although it was a minor role in a film that
already had a very crowded cast, most fans
felt as though Levi was a great replacement
for the part, and his dry bravado worked well
with the Asgardian swordsman.
Although Levi's Fandral had a brief and fatal
cameo in Thor: Ragnarok, he had apparently
already reached his wit's end with Marvel.
As he told CinemaBlend, he was actually hoping
for his character to be killed off because
Marvel had failed to develop any of the Warriors
Three, and he was apparently grateful that
Cate Blanchett's Hela finished the job in
Ragnarok.
In the second season of Amazon's Golden-Globe
winning series The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel , Rachel
Brosnahan's newly-divorced Midge Maisel vacations
with her family to the Catskills in upstate
New York.
It's here that Midge is set-up with dreamy
doctor Benjamin Ettenberg, played with memorable
swagger by Zachary Levi.
Midge and Benjamin have a rocky start, but
eventually their undeniable chemistry gets
the best of both of them.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
Levi admitted that although he'd seen the
series' pilot, he actually didn't know that
the show was picked up before he signed on:
"Then I got an offer to join, so my first
bit of homework was bingeing the first season,
all in essentially a day, and I immediately
wanted to be a part of this.
It's so well executed on every level, from
the top down, and to get to share screen time
with Rachel Brosnahan in that role, that's
an offer you can't refuse."
"People think if they buy me things I'll work
harder to keep them alive."
"Are they right?
Yes."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.